this is the Onion News Network keeping
you safe from the lights we begin
tonight with an update on a story we've
been following all week
how does Stephenson the 16-year old girl
from Detroit accused of stabbing a
classmate to death with a screwdriver
last month at her arraignment this
afternoon Hannah received the harshest
possible sentencing from the judge she
will be tried as a black adult due to
the extreme and violent nature of this
crime this court finds it fitting to try
the defendant as an african-american and
forth you will be referred to for the
jury by the name bond Elle Brown
[Laughter]
yes yes hey listen I know I'll call The
Onion's cuz y'all making me cry it's
funny cause it's true
kids at our trial as adults is bigoted
worst sentence but a white poor girl get
in sentence as a black man oh and just
in case you guys have left all the race
card stuff it is a prone fact even when
you go now if you've been when you
account for prior convictions black
males because we get way more time
yelling others so fast
it's a finesse effect another fun fact I
feel get less time in jail than their
military body away from one extreme to
the other once the trial begins next
week all courtroom images of Hannah will
depict her as a 300-pound muscular black
man and jury members will be instructed
to imagine her as such we're going to do
our best to make sure that Hannah is
treated with the sympathy and
sensitivity that she as a photogenic
white girl deserves this is America
nobody deserves to be treated as a black
man nobody deserves to be treated as a
black man
[Music]
now that hannah has been ruled black the
court has instructed local media to
assume she's guilty and the police have
retro actively charged her with
assaulting her arresting officer had as
two dozen character witnesses had been
replaced by a single crack addict who
goes by the name of Skaggs Anna's
parents are of course planning to appeal
the ruling listen you've got some of the
greatest riders on guys fire I know it's
like it's a very cool put is its deal
saying that their daughter should add
most be tried as a black celebrity or a
stunningly beautiful Filipino lady ah I
mean some I hear a story like that it
makes me so glad I'm exempt from the
legal system Oh as far as satire goes I
have ten out of ten for me listen
it's [ __ ] up because in satire
sometimes you get much more truth than
in real life journalism yeah well me
comedy has a way of making us accept
certain realities due to the humor it
cuts a lot of attention that's cream or
discussing something difficult so it
makes it much more palatable and then
you know this is a very serious issue
and prison industrial complex the fact
that black he will get incarcerated at
much higher rates that males get in car
so much more higher rates those are
serious topics put the humor and the
satire of it makes it easy yes
so for me not only was this truthful but
it was [ __ ] fun one I can tell you
right now I know comedians helped write
that Darren that's for sure a hundred
percent that's for sure onions employed
a lot of great comedians respecting the
idea because actually was genius that's
like a two-minute sketch but it was like
I packed so much information that you
don't even get in real life journalism
and that's what I love about it like
this [ __ ] was fun
it's satire with the point and I think
anytime you're able to poke find out
truths in the world that's always worth
it if you can be really funny and
original onions the greatest and you
know what is that part of me that really
wish this thing will like that
what people beat you to like black
people yeah but anyway sorry now I
thought that [ __ ] was genius
yo audience members now it's up to you
guys tell us what you guys think and
yeah that's pretty much it
see alright so that's it for today's
video if you guys like that be sure to
LIKE subscribe Facebook YouTube
we don't put everything on Facebook
because YouTube's our main
[ __ ] follow us on Instagram all that
good stuff we got a patreon page so if
you want donate a little bit money you
know give us a little thumbs up then we
do a little I definitely went the wrong
direction yeah but that's this so you
know thanks holler a dollar makes me
holler